OK, so this week, like the rest of us, Ohio is going to the polls. And in Ohio, there are more people who vote Republican there, but not a lot more. Donald Trump and Barack Obama each carried the state twice.
好的，这周和我们大家一样，俄亥俄州也要进行投票。在俄亥俄州，投共和党票的人数确实比投民主党的人数多，但差距并不大。唐纳德·特朗普和巴拉克·奥巴马都曾两次赢下该州。
If the Congressional delegation reflected the breakdown of Democratic and Republican voters in the state, they would have eight Republicans and seven Democrats sitting in the House of Representatives. But right now, it is not that. There are not seven Democrats. There are four. And that's probably the best outcome the Democrats can hope for in this week's election. In fact, they could do worse, which, of course, would hurt the Democrats' chances for holding control of the US House of Representatives.
如果国会代表团能够反映该州民主党和共和党选民的构成比例，那么众议院里应该有八名共和党人和七名民主党人。但现在的情况并非如此。民主党人不是七名，而是四名。而这可能是民主党在本周选举中能期待的最好结果了。事实上，他们的情况可能会更糟，这当然会损害民主党维持对美国众议院控制权的机会。
And why, you may ask, are Democrats only going to take two or three or four seats and not seven? At one level, it doesn't have anything to do with the issues or politics or Biden or anything like that. It really just comes down to gerrymandering.
你可能会问，为什么民主党只能拿到两三个或四个席位，而不是七个？从某种程度上讲，这与议题、政治倾向、拜登或其他类似因素毫无关系。归根结底，这只是选区划分不公的问题。
The districts are drawn to favor the Republicans, mostly by smashing lots of Democrats into just a few districts, giving Republicans majorities in the rest of them. In Ohio, those districts are about as bad as they come. But here's what's different about Ohio.
选区划分倾向于共和党，主要是通过将大量民主党选民挤入少数几个选区，从而使共和党在其余选区获得多数优势。在俄亥俄州，这些选区的划分简直糟糕透顶。但俄亥俄州的情况有所不同。
A few years back, something very unusual happened. Republicans and Democrats came together, and they said, enough. They changed the state's constitution so the districts would be drawn fairly at last. 70% of voters in 2015 and 2018 approved this. Arnold Schwarzenegger-- he's fought against gerrymandering going back to when he was governor of California. He tweeted a congratulatory video.
几年前，发生了一件非常不同寻常的事。共和党人和民主党人走到了一起，他们说：受够了。他们修改了州宪法，以便最终能公正地划分选区。2015年和2018年，70%的选民批准了这一举措。阿诺德·施瓦辛格——从他担任加州州长时起，他就一直在反对选区划分不公。他发推特发布了一段祝贺视频。
And I also want to congratulate the legislators, Democrats and Republicans alike, for coming together, and all of you together have terminated gerrymandering in Ohio. That's fantastic.
我也要祝贺议员们，无论是民主党人还是共和党人，感谢你们齐心协力，你们所有人共同终结了俄亥俄州的选区划分不公。这太棒了。
Hard not to love how on-brand that guy is.
很难不爱这个家伙如此鲜明的个人风格。
That's a huge victory, getting rid of gerrymandering, which is the worst thing in America.
这是一个巨大的胜利，摆脱了选区划分不公，这是美国最糟糕的事情。
It was a rare kumbaya political moment. The Republican governor of Ohio, John Kasich, was praising Democrats and voters rights groups, making idealistic speeches.
那是一个难得的政治和解时刻。俄亥俄州共和党州长约翰·卡西奇称赞了民主党人和选民权利组织，并发表了理想主义的演讲。
Listen, this is incredible, what they did. We're now a model for the country, and it just means we're going to have fair elections. They're going to be more competitive. Why does this issue matter so much? Well, because when you draw lines in such a way that only one party can win the district, it creates a polarizing effect.
听着，他们所做的一切简直不可思议。我们现在成为了全国的榜样，这意味着我们将举行公平的选举。选举将会更具竞争性。为什么这个问题如此重要？嗯，因为当你以这种方式划分选区，使得只有一个政党能赢时，它会产生一种两极分化的效应。
That's because, he says, when candidates don't have to worry about voters from the other party voting them out, their views get more extreme. They play to their base, court voters from their own party with whatever red meat issues are popular.
这是因为，他说，当候选人不必担心另一党的选民会投票将他们赶下台时，他们的观点就会变得更加极端。他们迎合自己的基本盘，用任何受欢迎的激进议题来拉拢本党选民。
And that means we move farther and farther apart as a nation. And it all leads to-- [COUGHS] excuse me-- getting nothing done. This is really big time. This is the beginning of an effort to end all this polarization, get people to communicate, to listen to one another. That's what this is about.
这意味着我们作为一个国家会渐行渐远。这一切最终导致——（咳嗽声）不好意思——什么事也做不成。这真的是一件大事。这是结束所有这种两极分化、让人们沟通并倾听彼此努力的开始。这就是这件事的意义所在。
And so the new rules of map making went into effect. Ohio headed into the utopian post-gerrymandering world where people would communicate and polarization would shrink, at least a little. And in 2021, they got their very first chance to draw new completely fair maps, the maps for the election that we are holding this month and for the decade ahead. And then, a funny thing happened.
于是，新的制图规则生效了。俄亥俄州进入了一个选区划分不公后的乌托邦世界，人们本可以沟通，两极分化会缩小，至少会缩小一点点。2021年，他们第一次有机会绘制完全公平的新地图，即我们这个月要举行的选举以及未来十年的选举地图。然后，发生了一件有趣的事。
Ohio's newly drawn legislative maps have now been deemed invalid and, in fact, unconstitutional.
俄亥俄州新绘制的立法地图现在被认定无效，事实上，被认定为违宪。
The Ohio Supreme Court said the maps drawn by Republican mapmakers were gerrymandered still. They didn't do the basic things they just enacted a constitutional amendment to do. But OK, everybody knows it's hard for old dogs to learn new tricks. Partisans will be partisans, maybe to be expected. Slapped down by the court, lawmakers got another shot. They redrew the maps. Weeks later--
俄亥俄州最高法院表示，由共和党地图绘制者绘制的地图仍然存在选区划分不公。他们根本没有做他们刚刚通过宪法修正案要求做的基本事情。不过没关系，大家都知道老狗学不会新把戏。党派中人终究是党派中人，这也许是可以预见的。被法院驳回后，立法者们又获得了一次机会。他们重新绘制了地图。几周后——
Well, now to breaking political news tonight. Ohio's Supreme Court is sending Ohio's House and Senate back to the drawing board again. Today the Supreme Court ruled the state's redistricting maps as unconstitutional for the second time in less than a month. Well, now--
好的，现在来关注今晚突发的政治新闻。俄亥俄州最高法院再次让俄亥俄州众议院和参议院重回制图板。今天，最高法院在一个月内第二次裁定该州的重新划分选区地图违宪。好的，现在——
That was February. Lawmakers tried again to draw an ungerrymandered map. And in March--
那是二月份的事。立法者们再次尝试绘制一份没有选区划分不公的地图。到了三月——
Welcome into Action News at 4 on this St Patrick's Day. And the third time not a lucky charm for Ohio Republican mapmakers.
欢迎收看4点的行动新闻，今天是圣帕特里克节。对俄亥俄州共和党制图者来说，第三次并不是幸运符。
The state Supreme Court overturned another set of general assembly maps late Thursday night.
州最高法院周四深夜推翻了另一套大会选区地图。
I'm sure you see where this is going. April.
我敢肯定你知道接下来会发生什么。四月。
Well, 10 TV news at 5 begins with several breaking news stories tonight. We start at the Ohio Supreme Court. There, the justices struck down redistricting maps as gerrymandered for the fourth time.
好的，5点的10频道新闻今晚从几个突发新闻报道开始。我们从俄亥俄州最高法院开始。在那里，法官们第四次以选区划分不公为由驳回了重新划分选区的地图。
And then, May.
然后是五月。
The Ohio Supreme Court rejecting legislative maps for a fifth time.
俄亥俄州最高法院第五次否决了立法地图。
OK, yes, in all, the maps of Ohio State House were rejected five times. And then, on top of that, when it came to its representatives to the US Congress, those districts were rejected twice. And then, time ran out. There's no more time to redraw any maps. Because of all that, Ohio is going to be going to the polls this week with maps its Supreme Court has declared unconstitutional-- illegal, just deeply gerrymandered.
好吧，是的，总共来说，俄亥俄州众议院的地图被否决了五次。此外，在涉及美国国会代表时，这些选区也两次被否决。然后，时间耗尽了。没有更多时间重新绘制任何地图了。正因为如此，俄亥俄州本周将带着最高法院宣布违宪的地图——非法的、深深陷入选区划分不公的地图——去进行投票。
How did they end up here? How is that even possible? Well, that's a story I'm here to tell you today. A bunch of states are going to the polls this week with gerrymandered districts that heavily favor one side over the other. But in Ohio this year, it wasn't supposed to be that way.
他们怎么会走到这一步？这怎么可能？嗯，这就是我今天在这里要讲的故事。本周，许多州都将带着明显倾向于一方的、经过不公正划分的选区进行投票。但在俄亥俄州，今年本不该是这样的。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's "This American Life." I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us, voters.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。选民们，请留下来。
Act one-- They made each other a pledge. Unheard of. Absurd. OK, so when I first started looking into this, one of the things I really didn't understand was how did Ohio end up with this constitutional amendment at all to fix the way they draw districts. After all, if you think about it, whichever party was in power, they had no motive at all to want to change.
第一幕——他们互相做出了承诺。闻所未闻。荒谬。好吧，当我刚开始研究这个的时候，我真正不理解的事情之一就是俄亥俄州到底是如何最终通过这项宪法修正案来修复他们绘制选区方式的。毕竟，如果你仔细想想，无论哪个党派掌权，他们根本没有任何想要改变的动机。
Democrats, in fact, happily gerrymandered for years and years, and they killed gerrymandering reform in Ohio-- most recently, back in 2010. Lately, of course, it's been the Republicans drawing unfair districts. The majorities are so overwhelming at this point, the Senate president has said, publicly, "We can kind of do what we want," which is true.
事实上，民主党人多年来一直乐于搞选区划分不公，并且他们在俄亥俄州扼杀了选区划分改革——最近一次是在2010年。当然，近来一直是共和党人在绘制不公平的选区。此时此刻，多数派的优势已经非常压倒性了，参议院议长甚至公开表示：“我们想做什么就可以做什么”，这确实是真的。
Republican supermajorities in Ohio pass laws like, for example, the one that banned abortion, even in the case of rape and incest. In June, you probably remember this led to a 10-year-old Ohio girl who'd been raped to have to go to Indiana for an abortion.
俄亥俄州的共和党超级多数派通过了诸如禁止堕胎之类的法律，即使在强奸和乱伦的情况下也是如此。六月，你可能还记得，这导致一名在俄亥俄州被强奸的10岁女孩不得不去印第安纳州进行堕胎。
In a state that a majority supports Roe v. Wade, I dare say 5% or fewer Ohioans agree with how that 10-year-old was treated.
在一个大多数人支持罗诉韦德案的州，我敢说只有5%或更少的俄亥俄州人认同那个10岁女孩所受的待遇。
David Pepper used to run the Democratic Party in the state, but became so alarmed at the kinds of laws he saw the Republican supermajority passing and the way they rigged maps to stay in power, that he wrote a book, Laboratories of Autocracy, documenting it.
戴维·佩珀过去曾负责该州的民主党工作，但由于对共和党超级多数派通过的法律种类以及他们操纵选区以保持权力的方式感到如此震惊，他写了一本书《专制的实验室》，记录了这一切。
It's a state that only a few months ago passed a bill because they were so worried about trans athletes that said that, on demand, girls playing on sports teams and of all ages should on demand have genital inspections-- genital inspections. But that extremism does not reflect the people. Very few people would support it.
就在几个月前，该州还通过了一项法案，因为他们太担心跨性别运动员，该法案称，所有年龄段参加运动队的女孩，如果需要，应该接受生殖器检查——生殖器检查。但这种极端主义并不能反映人民的意愿。几乎没有人会支持它。
Same with guns-- this is a state that the vast majorities would support background checks. The legislature passes laws where only 10% or so agree with them. And so the gerrymandering is, again, not just about a unearned majority control. It's what is fueling the extremism and behavior from politicians that I think most Americans can't understand. It's about no competition whatsoever.
枪支问题也一样——在这个州，绝大多数人会支持背景调查。而立法机关通过的法律，只有约10%的人同意。所以，选区划分不公再次重申，不仅仅是关于不劳而获的多数控制权。这才是助长政客极端主义和行为的根源，我想大多数美国人都无法理解。这是因为完全没有竞争。
So whoever's in power has good reasons to keep gerrymandering. And in Ohio, whenever anybody has tried to stop them, they've failed. It's been a long history of hard fought battles going back to the early '80s. Catherine Turcer, who runs one of the do-gooder groups that's active on this issue, Common Cause Ohio, she jumped into the fight in the 1990s when she first heard about gerrymandering and got hooked.
所以谁掌权，谁就有充分的理由继续搞选区划分不公。在俄亥俄州，每当有人试图阻止他们时，都失败了。从80年代初开始，这就是一场艰苦战斗的悠久历史。凯瑟琳·瑟瑟经营着一个在此问题上活跃的公益组织“共同事业俄亥俄”，她在90年代第一次听说选区划分不公时就投入了这场斗争，并从此深陷其中。
You know, at first, it just sounds like some kind of weird conspiracy, something that happens every 10 years behind closed doors, and it's--
你知道，起初，这听起来就像某种奇怪的阴谋，每10年在闭门造车中发生一次，而且——
Nearly everybody you're going to hear this hour has some moment like this, where the arcane details of political redistricting took over their lives. In the '90s, Catherine gathered signatures to put a constitutional amendment on the Ohio ballot, which takes hundreds of thousands of signatures. They couldn't collect enough. She worked on the statewide campaign, and they tried again in 2005. This time, they got on the ballot, and voters rejected them horribly-- 70% to 30%. Tried again in 2012, lost again, similar margin. Catherine describes what that feels like this way.
这一小时你听到的几乎每个人都有过这样的时刻，政治选区重划的晦涩细节接管了他们的生活。在90年代，凯瑟琳收集签名以将宪法修正案列入俄亥俄州选票，这需要数十万个签名。他们没能收集到足够多的签名。她在全州范围内开展运动，他们曾在2005年再次尝试。这一次，他们成功列入选票，但被选民以70%对30%的比例惨痛地否决了。2012年再次尝试，再次失败，票数差距相似。凯瑟琳这样描述那种感觉。
I had to-- I was in a really terrible car accident, and I had to relearn to walk. And--
我不得不——我经历了一场非常可怕的车祸，我不得不重新学习走路。并且——
Wow.
哇。
--I've recovered from cancer. I have gotten a divorce. None of them are as awful as losing a ballot measure.
——我从癌症中恢复过来。我离过婚。这些都没有输掉一项投票提案那么糟糕。
Wait, a divorce-- I just want to go through the list again. A divorce--
等等，离婚——我只是想再过一遍这个清单。离婚——
[LAUGHS]
（笑声）
--cancer, and getting in a terrible car accident where you have to learn to walk afterwards--
——癌症，还有经历一场可怕的车祸，之后不得不重新学习走路——
Yes.
是的。
--not as bad as losing a ballot measure.
——没有输掉一项投票提案那么糟糕。
Because you just have to do it all over again.
因为你只是不得不重新再做一遍。
And why did you lose so badly, like if this is just sort of sensible good government, let's have fair district lines?
既然这只是某种明智的良好治理，让我们有公平的选区界线，为什么你们会输得那么惨？
So the opposition-- oh my gosh, they spent so much money-- just talked about how crazy the redistricting map would be, and then they spent millions of dollars-- basically things like faceless bureaucrats are going to draw the district lines. Oh, and they're going to spend unlimited amounts of money on this mapmaking process. You have no idea how much money they're going to be spending.
所以反对派——天哪，他们花了很多很多钱——只是谈论重新划分选区地图会有多疯狂，然后他们花了数百万美元——基本上是说一些无名的官僚要来绘制选区界线之类的东西。哦，而且他们将在这次地图绘制过程中花费无限量的钱。你根本不知道他们会花多少钱。
So the year all this partisanship ended, or at least paused, and all the parties sat down to fix mapmaking in Ohio, was 2014. And there are a bunch of reasons that it happened that year. One big reason-- the map that the Republicans had just drawn in the last round of map making was so undeniably lopsided, some of the laws the new majority started passing were more inflammatory than in the past, especially this measure to try to bust up public unions, which led to protests and a ballot measure.
所以，这种党派之争结束，或者至少暂停，所有党派坐下来修复俄亥俄州地图绘制的那一年是2014年。那一年发生这种情况有很多原因。一个主要原因——共和党人在上一轮地图绘制中刚刚绘制的地图太不可否认地不平衡了，新多数派开始通过的一些法律比过去更具煽动性，尤其是这项试图瓦解公共工会的措施，这导致了抗议和一项投票提案。
After that, a lot more people took notice of how weird the districts looked. Republicans started worrying that the Democrats and the good government groups were going to bring a ballot measure to change the constitution and end gerrymandering. And of course, they defeated these kinds of measures in the past, but this time, there was one new factor that was going to make it harder.
在那之后，更多人注意到选区看起来是多么奇怪。共和党人开始担心民主党人和良政团体将提出一项投票提案来修改宪法并结束选区划分不公。当然，他们过去曾挫败过这类提案，但这一次，有一个新的因素会使其变得更加困难。
And to explain that part, let me just introduce you to the mastermind behind the Republican strategy in Ohio when it comes to redistricting and map drawing, one of the leading Republicans in the state, Matt Huffman. Back when he and I spoke, I was still trying to figure out who was the person who first had the idea for the 2015 constitutional amendment to curtail gerrymandering, like who is the person who got everybody else on board. Somebody had told me that it was Catherine Turcer, the woman from Common Cause. Matt Huffman was very clear on this point.
为了解释那一部分，让我为你介绍一下俄亥俄州共和党在重新划分选区和绘制地图方面的战略策划者，该州领先的共和党人之一，马特·赫夫曼。当我们交谈时，我还在试图找出谁是第一个提出2015年宪法修正案以遏制选区划分不公想法的人，比如是谁让其他人加入进来的。有人告诉我那是“共同事业”组织的凯瑟琳·瑟瑟。马特·赫夫曼在这一点上非常明确。
It was not Catherine Turcer. It was not Catherine Turcer. It was a young state representative Matt Huffman who introduced this, and I'll tell you why-- personally, why I ended up doing that.
那不是凯瑟琳·瑟瑟。那不是凯瑟琳·瑟瑟。是年轻的州众议员马特·赫夫曼提出了这个建议，我会告诉你我个人为什么最终会那样做。
That checks out, by the way, with people who are close to the process. Matt Huffman says all this began after he fought to stop one of those ballot initiatives to get rid of gerrymandering. This is the one in 2012, the second one in 10 years.
顺便说一句，这与接近该过程的人士的说法相符。马特·赫夫曼说这一切始于他为阻止其中一项旨在消除选区划分不公的投票倡议而奋斗之后。这是2012年的那一次，10年来的第二次。
People spend a lot of money saying, yes, no, this is outrageous, gerrymandering. And I went around the state, and I raised money and lots of folks said, gee, we seem to be doing this a lot. We'll give you money, but isn't there anything you can do so we don't have to keep having this fight every three or four years?
人们花了很多钱说，是的，不，这太离谱了，选区划分不公。我走遍全州，筹集资金，很多人说，天哪，我们似乎经常做这件事。我们会给你钱，但没有什么办法能让我们不用每三四年就得一直进行这种争斗吗？
Yeah, the thing that I had heard was that the Chamber of Commerce said, like, we shouldn't be spending our money on this. We should be spending money on races and getting people to win. And that's right?
是的，我听说商会说过，我们不应该把钱花在这上面。我们应该把钱花在竞选上，让人们获胜。那是对的吗？
Yeah, well, that's a-- I mean, I'm not recalling a specific conversation in the Chamber of Commerce, but those, typically Republican, groups. People did say to me in 2012, we're not going to write checks for this anymore. Go solve the problem. Can't you come up with some compromise? We almost had one in 2010, the Republicans in the Senate. And I said, yeah, but the Democrats wouldn't do it. Well, maybe they'll do it now. So, OK, I'm going to take a shot at it.
是的，嗯，这是——我的意思是我不记得商会有过什么具体的谈话，但那些通常是共和党团体。人们确实在2012年对我说了，我们不会再为此开支票了。去解决这个问题吧。难道你就不能想出一个妥协方案吗？我们曾在2010年差点有一个，参议院的共和党人。我说，是的，但民主党人不肯做。好吧，也许他们现在肯了。所以，好吧，我要试一试。
Huffman sees himself as somebody who almost compulsively wants to jump at a problem and try to solve it, and even his opponents say that he is an enormously creative legislator. Back then, he'd just been through hearings where Democrats and Republicans both talked about what they'd want to see in a constitutional reform of gerrymandering.
赫夫曼认为自己是一个几乎强迫性地想要扑向问题并试图解决它的人，甚至他的反对者也说他是一位极具创造力的立法者。当时，他刚刚经历过听证会，民主党人和共和党人都谈论过他们希望在选区划分不公的宪法改革中看到什么。
And he and everybody else saw possibilities for compromise. So five negotiators went into a room in the State House for secret talks that one of them told me lasted 39 hours. Huffman and the bigwigs in the parties signed on, and the two sides came to relatively quick agreement-- on some of the rules, anyway-- for map drawing that now appear in the Constitution.
他和所有其他人都看到了妥协的可能性。于是五名谈判代表进入州议会大厦进行秘密会谈，其中一人告诉我持续了39个小时。赫夫曼和党内大佬们签了字，双方在相对较短的时间内达成了协议——至少在地图绘制的一些规则上——这些规则现在出现在宪法中。
Districts have to be as compact as possible. They shouldn't sprawl out in weird shapes. Whenever possible, if there's a township or county, it should all sit in one district, or if it's too big for that, in two districts, with as few divisions in it as possible. I was told by other negotiators that last item was very important to Matt Huffman during the negotiations.
选区必须尽可能紧凑。它们不应该以奇怪的形状蔓延。只要有可能，如果有一个乡镇或县，它应该全部坐落在一个选区内，或者如果它太大了，就在两个选区内，并尽可能减少分裂。其他谈判代表告诉我，最后一项在谈判期间对马特·赫夫曼非常重要。
And when I talked to him, he said that particular item was helpful to him personally as the guy in charge of drawing the Republican political maps, and not because it helped him fight Democrats. I thought this actually gave a fascinating glimpse into what it is like to be a political boss like him, trying to keep his allies in line and on the same page.
当我与他交谈时，他说那个特别的条款对他个人作为负责绘制共和党政治地图的人很有帮助，并不是因为它帮助他打击民主党。我认为这实际上让人着迷地一窥像他这样的政治大佬是什么样的，试图让他的盟友保持一致并保持在同一页面上。
Much of the problem with redistricting is not party versus party. It's intraparty wrangling and ridiculous demands made by legislators about having this county in their district-- or their hometown.
重新划分选区的大部分问题不是政党对政党。而是党内争论以及立法者关于在他们的选区拥有这个县——或者他们的家乡——的荒谬要求。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
And it's not-- it's not fair. It's not realistic. I want to have that township because that's where my daughter lives or my restaurant is there, or I at least want to be included in that congressional district because-- and this happened because I may want to run for Congress because I think that guy is going to retire. We can say, we're not allowed to do that because we're not allowed to split townships in half. And it's an answer to a lot of bad behavior on both sides of the aisle.
而且这不是——这不公平。这不现实。我想要那个乡镇，因为我女儿住在那里，或者我的餐馆在那里，或者我至少想被包括在那个国会选区内，因为——而且这发生了——因为我可能想竞选国会议员，因为我觉得那个家伙要退休了。我们可以说，我们不被允许这样做，因为我们不允许把乡镇一分为二。这是对两党内部很多不良行为的一种回答。
Meanwhile, what Democrats and good government groups wanted in the constitution was something to guarantee that the district maps would not favor one party over another. And they knew it wasn't enough just to say the words, "You can't favor one party over another."
与此同时，民主党人和良政团体在宪法中想要的是保证选区地图不会偏袒任何一个政党的东西。他们知道，仅仅说“你不能偏袒任何一个政党”这句话是不够的。
Florida put that wording into its constitution, and it was vague enough that it led to years of lawsuits. So these people in Ohio wanted some kind of measurement in the constitution, some way to determine whether a map was fair or not that everybody agreed to. Catherine explains what they came up with.
佛罗里达州将其措辞纳入了宪法，但它太模糊了，导致了多年的诉讼。所以俄亥俄州的这些人想要宪法中的某种衡量标准，某种每个人都同意的确定地图是否公平的方法。凯瑟琳解释了他们想出的办法。
Essentially, what's in the Ohio constitution is that we look at the statewide elections over the past decade. So in 10 years, those statewide races-- and you can think of president. You can think of senator, governor, et cetera. You take all of those. You put them together, meaning you add up the Democratic votes, and you add up the Republican votes.
本质上，俄亥俄州宪法的内容是我们查看过去十年的全州选举。所以10年来，那些全州性的竞选——你可以想到总统。你可以想到参议员、州长等等。你把所有这些都拿出来。你把它们放在一起，这意味着你把民主党的选票加起来，把共和党的选票加起来。
I mean, you do that in Ohio, you see that 46% of the votes that people cast were for Democrats over the last 10 years. 54% were for Republicans. And so 46% of its state house districts should be districts with more Democrats in them, and 54% of those districts should have more Republicans. One of the five negotiators, former political science professor Richard Gunther, came up with this idea, which he calls proportional representation.
我的意思是，你在俄亥俄州这样做，你看到过去10年来人们投下的选票中，46%是投给民主党人的。54%是投给共和党人的。所以46%的州议会选区应该是民主党人较多的选区，而54%的选区应该有更多的共和党人。五名谈判代表之一，前政治学教授理查德·冈瑟，提出了这个想法，他称之为比例代表制。
Meaning that the share of seats leaning towards one party or another should closely correspond to the share of votes cast for those two parties. So you're starting from a level playing field.
这意味着倾向于某一个党派的席位份额应该与这两个政党获得的选票份额紧密对应。所以你从一个公平的竞争环境开始。
So you invent this thing.
所以你发明了这个东西。
Yep. It is not in any constitution of any state in the US.
是的。它不在美国任何一个州的任何宪法中。
Any state but Ohio.
除了俄亥俄州之外的任何州。
When voters overwhelmingly approved the new rules, the Democrats and good government types were cautiously optimistic, like Catherine Turcer. She said they all knew it wasn't perfect. They made compromises. It was the only way to get it passed.
当选民以压倒性多数批准新规则时，民主党人和良政类型的人持谨慎乐观态度，比如凯瑟琳·瑟瑟。她说他们都知道这并不完美。他们做出了妥协。这是通过它的唯一途径。
There might be a few games, but that these elected officials would do their best to meet the rules.
可能会有一些博弈，但这些民选官员会尽其所能遵守规则。
I understand that, but emotionally, did you just feel like, we did it? We had this goal, and we and we won. Did you feel like that?
我理解，但在情感上，你是否觉得，我们做到了？我们有了这个目标，并且我们赢了。你有这种感觉吗？
Oh my gosh. Not only did I think we won, I was like, I could retire. It was like, oh my goodness, there's like light at the end of the tunnel. And I feel sad for that girl, you know, that person.
天哪。我不仅认为我们赢了，我还觉得，我可以退休了。就像是，哦，天哪，隧道尽头有光了。而且我为那个女孩感到难过，你知道，那个人。
You feel sad for 2015 Catherine Turcer.
你为2015年的凯瑟琳·瑟瑟感到难过。
[LAUGHS] Yes, 2015 Catherine Turcer who believed that we had set the stage for truly meaningful elections.
（笑声）是的，那个相信我们已经为真正有意义的选举奠定了基础的2015年凯瑟琳·瑟瑟。
Coming up-- what goes wrong when Ohio tries out its new constitutional amendment and draws its very first maps under the rules? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来——当俄亥俄州尝试其新的宪法修正案并根据规则绘制其第一张地图时，出了什么问题？一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- Mapmaker, Mapmaker, Make Me a Map, the story of why Ohio is going to the polls this week with election maps the state's own Supreme Court says violate the state's constitution. We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two-- Sunrise, Sunset slash Is This the Little Constitutional Amendment I Carried?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——制图师，制图师，给我画一张地图，关于为什么俄亥俄州本周要带着该州最高法院称违反州宪法的选举地图去投票的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕——日出，日落，斜线，这是我背负的那份小宪法修正案吗？
OK, so in 2021, Ohioans sat down to make the electoral maps for the election that we're holding this week, using their new constitutional amendment for the very first time, taking it out for a spin. And as you already know, what unfolded was kind of a disaster.
好的，所以2021年，俄亥俄州人坐下来为我们本周要举行的选举制作选举地图，这是他们第一次使用新的宪法修正案，拿它去试运行。正如你已经知道的那样，展开的情况简直是一场灾难。
They had to make three maps in all. One of those was defining congressional districts for the US House of Representatives, then two maps for the Ohio State House, one for the Ohio Senate, one for the Ohio House of Representatives. OK, so three maps, similar things happen with all three.
他们总共不得不制作三张地图。其中一张是定义美国众议院的国会选区，然后是两张俄亥俄州议会的地图，一张是俄亥俄州参议院的，一张是俄亥俄州众议院的。好的，所以三张地图，三张都发生了类似的事情。
And I'm going to tell you the story of what happened with the map for the Ohio House of Representatives because it was the most bitterly divisive. And also, there are things in gerrymandering that usually happen all the time around the country behind closed doors that here play out in public. And it took some pretty shocking turns along the way.
我要告诉你关于俄亥俄州众议院地图发生的事情的故事，因为它是最令人感到痛苦的分歧。而且，选区划分不公中通常在全国各地闭门发生的事情，在这里在公开场合上演了。并且在过程中出现了一些相当令人震惊的转折。
And I call this meeting to order. We'll now proceed to the presentation of a member appointments to the Ohio redistricting commission.
现在我宣布会议开始。我们现在将进行俄亥俄州选区重划委员会成员任命的陈述。
The new constitutional amendment created a redistricting commission with seven members to draw the state's electoral maps. This was their first meeting in August of last year. Seven members mandated by the amendment were some of the most powerful people in the state-- the governor, secretary of state, and auditor, and then from the state legislature, two Republican lawmakers and two Democrats.
新的宪法修正案成立了一个有七名成员的选区重划委员会来绘制该州的选举地图。这是他们去年八月的第一次会议。修正案规定的七名成员是该州一些最有权势的人——州长、州务卿和审计长，然后来自州议会，两名共和党议员和两名民主党议员。
Matt Huffman, the Republican who was behind the amendment's creation, he was on the committee, still calling the shots. He was also by this time a state senator and president of the Ohio Senate. Vernon Sykes was the leading Democrat on the commission and its co-chair. He'd been the Democratic party's main negotiator, Huffman's counterpart when they were drafting the constitutional amendment.
马特·赫夫曼，这个修正案创建背后的共和党人，他在委员会中，仍然掌握着指挥权。到这时他也是一名州参议员和俄亥俄州参议院议长。弗农·赛克斯是委员会的首席民主党人及其联合主席。他是民主党的主要谈判代表，当他们起草宪法修正案时，他是赫夫曼的对手。
Sykes is such a hardcore anti-gerrymandering guy that in his first term in office back in 1983, he went to the Democrats, who at that point were running things-- they were the majority. He went to the leaders of his own party and told them it was unfair the way that they were drawing the maps. They should change.
赛克斯是一个如此坚定的反选区划分不公的家伙，以至于在1983年的第一个任期内，他去找了当时掌权的民主党人——他们是多数派。他去找自己政党的领导人，并告诉他们他们划分地图的方式是不公平的。他们应该改变。
It was a difficult row to hoe and really couldn't convince them to do that.
这是一条艰难的道路，真的无法说服他们那样做。
Like, did they say, like, are you crazy?
就像，他们说了，比如，你疯了吗？
Yeah, that was basically the terminology that was used. They thought I was naive and young and inexperienced and-- and I would get over it.
是的，基本上用的就是那个术语。他们认为我太天真、年轻且缺乏经验——而且我会克服它的。
Obviously, he did not get over it, and now here he sat, four decades later. In all, it was five Republicans on the committee, two Democrats. Mapmaking got a late start in Ohio because the new census data was late. But then, finally, on September 9 of last year--
显然，他没有克服它，现在他坐在这里，四十年后。总而言之，委员会里有五名共和党人，两名民主党人。俄亥俄州的制图开始得比较晚，因为新的人口普查数据晚了。但随后，终于，在去年9月9日——
Mr. Co-Chair?
联合主席先生？
Yes.
是的。
I would-- pursuant to Rule 10 of the commission, I would like to present to the commission a proposed General Assembly district plan for all 99 seats of the Ohio House of Representatives and all 33 seats of the Ohio Senate.
根据委员会第10条规则，我想向委员会提交一份拟议的俄亥俄州众议院所有99个席位和俄亥俄州参议院所有33个席位的大会选区计划。
That's Matt Huffman proposing maps that have been cooked up by the Republicans on their own. The new constitutional amendment actually calls for everybody on the commission to draft this map together, but Republicans said that the census data came in too late for that-- no time to collaborate. Democrats and the government types said that was nonsense. So this first map was like a cannon shot launching the war that followed.
那是马特·赫夫曼提议共和党人自己炮制的地图。新的宪法修正案实际上要求委员会里的每个人一起起草这张地图，但共和党人说人口普查数据来得太晚了——没有时间合作。民主党人和政府类型的人说那是无稽之谈。所以第一张地图就像发动随后的战争的炮击。
Thank you. At this time, we are ready for the presentation.
谢谢。现在，我们准备好进行陈述了。
The single most important thing about the map that anybody would want to know-- did it favor one party more than another? The Republicans didn't give any information about that at all in this first hearing. And mind you, they were doing all this at the very last minute. There were only six days before the constitution said they had to approve some map.
关于这张地图，任何人想知道的最重要的一件事——它是否比另一个政党更偏袒某一方？在这次第一次听证会上，共和党人根本没有提供任何相关信息。请注意，他们是在最后一分钟才做所有这些事情的。宪法规定他们必须批准某张地图，距离截止日期只有六天了。
Given the way the constitution was written, like we said earlier, 54% of Ohioans had been voting Republican over the previous decade, so most people figured that 54% of the districts should have Republican majorities. When the numbers were finally revealed, Republicans got a lot more than that. The map gave Republicans between 64% and 70% of all the districts. I asked a few people who are at these hearings to talk me through what they were like.
鉴于宪法的书写方式，就像我们之前说的，过去十年来，54%的俄亥俄州人一直在投票支持共和党，所以大多数人认为54%的选区应该是共和党多数。当数据最终公布时，共和党人得到的远不止这些。地图给了共和党人所有选区中64%到70%的份额。我问了几个参加这些听证会的人，让他们带我走一遍听证会是什么样的。
Katy Shanahan was there working with a group called the National Democratic Redistricting Committee. She personally had locked in on gerrymandering as her issue when she was in law school. She wrote a thesis evaluating how different states draw their maps and which are the most fair. Like everybody I spoke with, she expected the Republicans to try to gerrymander, you know, like, a little. But this first map--
凯蒂·沙纳汉在那里与一个名为“全国民主党选区重划委员会”的组织一起工作。当她在法学院时，她个人就锁定了选区划分不公作为她的议题。她写了一篇论文，评估不同州如何绘制地图以及哪些是最公平的。像我采访的所有人一样，她预料到共和党人会尝试搞选区划分不公，你知道，搞一点点。但这张第一张地图——
It's sort of impressive, [LAUGHS] in a bad way, that they managed to draw maps that were even worse than the ones that we had in place the last 10 years. After having helped write and pass a constitutional reform meant to curb that exact type of gerrymandering, the audacity of their action is breathtaking, no matter how predictable.
这有点令人印象深刻，（笑声）以一种糟糕的方式，他们设法绘制了比我们过去10年所拥有的地图更糟糕的地图。在帮助起草和通过旨在遏制那种确切类型的选区划分不公的宪法改革之后，他们行为的厚颜无耻令人叹为观止，无论它多么可预测。
The simple fact is that there are a lot of opinions about what that portion of the constitution means. For example--
简单的事实是，关于宪法的那部分意味着什么，有很多意见。例如——
During the hearings, Senator Huffman explained the number of Republican districts this way. He said that, under the constitution, the number of districts that each party gets is supposed to reflect the results in statewide elections over the previous 10 years. And results is the word the constitution uses-- results. But Huffman says, there are different ways that you can measure election results.
在听证会期间，赫夫曼参议员这样解释共和党选区的数量。他说，根据宪法，每个政党获得的选区数量应该反映过去10年来全州选举的结果。而“结果”这个词就是宪法使用的词——结果。但赫夫曼说，衡量选举结果有不同的方式。
Like, for instance, you can count the number of votes cast. If you do that, then Republicans won 54% of the votes, sure. But he said you could also count the number of races won-- governor, lieutenant governor, senator, all that. If you count the number of races, if you do it that way, Republicans won 81% of the races.
比如，你可以计算投下的选票数量。如果你这样做，那么共和党赢得了54%的选票，当然。但他说是的，你也可以计算赢得的竞选次数——州长、副州长、参议员，所有这些。如果你计算竞选次数，如果你那样做，共和党赢得了81%的竞选。
Again, Katy Shanahan.
还是凯蒂·沙纳汉。
And the explanation was, essentially, so we really could have gotten way worse maps, right? We could have drawn maps that gave us 81% of the seats, and that would have been fair. But we didn't do that, and isn't that so gracious of us to do that? And that was their explanation.
而解释基本上是，所以我们真的可以得到更糟糕的地图，对吧？我们可以绘制给我们81%席位的地图，那将是公平的。但我们没有那样做，我们这样做难道不是很仁慈吗？这就是他们的解释。
Yeah, what did you think of that argument?
是的，你觉得那个论点怎么样？
Well, excuse my French, but it's horseshit. Election results, I mean, I guess you could read that multiple ways. But to me, what that reads is, how have Ohioans voted in all of those races? If you're only counting who's won those elections, you're ignoring all of the other voters.
嗯，请原谅我的法语，但那是胡扯。选举结果，我的意思是，我想你可以用多种方式解读它。但对我来说，那解读为，俄亥俄州人在所有这些竞选中是如何投票的？如果你只计算谁赢得了这些选举，你就忽略了所有其他选民。
So there are some of those statewide races that were decided by a couple percentage points, which means you're essentially ignoring half of the voters who showed up to vote in those elections, which is not what I think what statewide preferences of the voters of Ohio means. It doesn't mean only count who's won those races and disregard everyone else who voted.
所以其中一些全州竞选是以几个百分点决定的，这意味着你基本上忽略了那些参加这些选举投票的选民中的一半，这在我看来并不是俄亥俄州选民全州偏好的意思。它并不意味着只计算谁赢了这些竞选，而无视所有其他投票的人。
I will say, the Democrats and good government types who negotiated the terms of this constitutional amendment with Matt Huffman found this interpretation of the word "results" to be so annoying. Like, they were there when this was written. Again, Catherine Turcer.
我要说，与马特·赫夫曼谈判这些宪法修正案条款的民主党人和良政类型的人发现对“结果”这个词的这种解释令人恼火。就像，当这被书写时，他们在场。还是凯瑟琳·瑟瑟。
And the notion that Matt Huffman didn't understand what representational fairness is is absolutely ludicrous. There were long conversations about it for years, really.
而且认为马特·赫夫曼不理解什么是代表性公平的概念绝对是荒谬的。确实有多年关于它的长期对话。
Richard Gunther said the same thing. Remember, he was one of the five negotiators who hammered out the terms of the amendment. He says, whenever they talked about election results, it was always about the number of votes, never about the number of races won.
理查德·冈瑟说了同样的话。记住，他是敲定修正案条款的五名谈判代表之一。他说，每当他们谈论选举结果时，总是关于选票数量，从来不是关于赢得的竞选数量。
No, that was never mentioned. And in fact, I've been a professional political scientist for five decades, and I've never seen election data used in that bizarre fashion.
不，那从来没有被提到过。事实上，我当了五十年的职业政治学家，我从未见过选举数据以那种怪异的方式被使用。
Matt Huffman totally sticks by his guns in this one. He told me the word in the constitution is "results." This notion that it means counting votes and not offices won--
马特·赫夫曼完全坚持他在这件事上的立场。他告诉我宪法中的词是“结果”。这个认为它意味着计算选票而不是赢得的职位的概念——
Well, why does the results mean that? Well, because I want it to? Because it's better for me? Well, those aren't really reasons. Well, you know--
嗯，为什么结果意味着那个？嗯，因为我想要它那样？因为它对我更好？嗯，那些并不是真正的理由。嗯，你知道——
But they're saying-- they're saying, just, that's what everybody talked about back then. Nobody talked about counting the number of offices.
但他们说——他们说，只是，那是每个人当时讨论的内容。没有人讨论计算职位的数量。
Yeah, then it should be in the constitution. This is like the agreement, right? We enter into a settlement agreement to settle our lawsuit, and later on, you say, well, on the side, you said you were paying court costs. I never said that.
是的，那么它应该写在宪法里。这就像是协议，对吧？我们订立了一份和解协议来解决我们的诉讼，后来，你说，好吧，私下里，你说过你要支付法庭费用。我从来没说过那样的话。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
Or on the side, I was supposed to get an extra $10,000. Remember, you mentioned it to me just before we signed the document? No. And so that's why we have the constitution and the votes--
或者私下里，我应该得到额外的10,000美元。记得，你就在我们签署文件之前对我提过它？不。所以这就是为什么我们有宪法和投票——
And you're saying the language-- the language-- the language doesn't specify. So it could be either one.
而且你是在说语言——语言——语言没有指定。所以它可能是任何一个。
Right.
对。
Yeah, Mr. President, so I've been trying to understand, as we've been talking to members of your staff and you yourself, how you believe that your--
是的，总统先生，所以我一直在试图理解，当我们和你的员工以及你自己谈话时，你如何相信你的——
In hearings over this, even the other Republicans on the redistricting commission seem to have trouble with Matt Huffman's rationale for this map. This is Ohio Secretary of State Frank LaRose, and as he is saying these words, the committee is in the final hour-- like, literally, it's the final hour before the constitutional deadline for approving a map. It's minutes before midnight on September 15.
在关于这个的听证会上，即使是选区重划委员会的其他共和党人似乎对马特·赫夫曼这张地图的基本原理也有困难。这是俄亥俄州州务卿弗兰克·拉罗斯，当他说出这些话时，委员会正处于最后时刻——真的，离宪法批准地图的截止日期只有最后一个小时了。这是9月15日午夜前几分钟。
LaRose is complaining that Huffman and his staff didn't even share information with other Republicans on the committee, never gave any explanation until then for why there were so many more Republican districts than the constitution seemed to allow.
拉罗斯抱怨赫夫曼和他的员工甚至没有与委员会的其他共和党人分享信息，直到那时才给出任何解释，说明为什么共和党选区比宪法似乎允许的多得多。
I, for one, have been asking for the rationale for days. Is there a reason why that wasn't shared with us until now?
我本人，几天来一直都在询问基本原理。有什么理由直到现在才与我们分享吗？
LaRose texted his chief of staff, quote, "This rationale is asinine. I should vote no." This came out in depositions a month later.
拉罗斯给他的办公厅主任发了短信，引用“这个基本原理是愚蠢的。我应该投反对票。”这一个月后在证词中被披露。
Further discussion on the motion. Governor DeWine?
对该动议的进一步讨论。德温州长？
Ohio's Republican Governor Mike DeWine also seemed concerned about how far Huffman had gone.
俄亥俄州的共和党州长迈克·德温似乎也对赫夫曼走得有多远感到担忧。
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I am deeply disappointed where we are tonight. I know-- I know that this committee could have produced a more clearly constitutional bill, but that's not the bill that we have in front of us. And I'm sorry we did not do that.
谢谢，主席先生。我对我们今晚所处的位置感到非常失望。我知道——我知道这个委员会本可以产生一个更明确的宪法法案，但那并不是我们面前的法案。我很抱歉我们没有这样做。
The governor and secretary of state both turned down a request for interviews. The commission didn't finally vote till after midnight, so they missed that deadline set by the constitution.
州长和州务卿都拒绝了采访请求。委员会直到午夜过后才最终投票，所以他们错过了宪法规定的那个截止日期。
Co-Chair Senator Sykes.
联合主席赛克斯参议员。
No.
不。
Co-Chair Speaker Cupp.
联合主席库普议长。
Yes.
是。
Governor DeWine?
德温州长？
Even Republicans who were critical of the maps voted for them. They passed on party lines-- 5 to 2. This is challenged in court, and the Ohio Supreme Court did not buy Huffman's explanation at all about the definition of the word "results." They ruled the map unconstitutional-- back to the drawing board.
甚至连批评地图的共和党人也投票赞成了它们。它们以党派路线通过——5比2。这在法庭上受到挑战，俄亥俄州最高法院根本不买赫夫曼关于“结果”一词定义的解释。他们裁定地图违宪——回到制图板。
Republicans created a second set of maps, again, on their own, again, with no input from the Democrats on the committee. This time, they tried something different. They gave the Democrats a few more districts that leaned their way but not as many as the Supreme Court called for. But there was a new problem, which the court pointed out when they rejected this set of maps.
共和党人再次制作了第二套地图，又是他们自己，同样没有任何来自委员会中民主党人的投入。这一次，他们尝试了一些不同的东西。他们给了民主党人几个更倾向于他们的选区，但没有最高法院要求的那么多。但出现了一个新问题，法院在否决这套地图时指出了这一点。
A third of the Democratic seats were just barely Democratic. Like, really, these seats were toss-ups, where Democrats had just a tiny fraction more voters than Republicans, like less than half of 1% more voters in most of the cases. Again, David Pepper used to chair the Democratic Party in the state.
三分之一的民主党席位只是勉强是民主党的。真的，这些席位是五五开，民主党选民只比共和党多一点点，在大多数情况下，比选民多出的比例不到0.5%。还是戴维·佩珀，过去曾担任该州民主党主席。
What the Supreme Court said correctly was, the only seats that were at risk of being lost were Democratic seats. That is not a fair map. You need to have in your side as many competitive seats as Democrats do.
最高法院正确指出的是，唯一有失去风险的席位是民主党席位。那不是一张公平的地图。你需要像民主党一样在你的这一侧拥有同样多的竞争性席位。
The Supreme Court said no to the second map because it violated the part of the constitution that says a map can't, quote, "favor or disfavor one party over another." The court gave the commission 10 days to try again. And the commission didn't meet until the 10th day, the very last day, February 17, 2022. And this time--
最高法院对第二张地图说了不，因为它违反了宪法中规定地图不能（引用）“偏袒或不偏袒一方”的部分。法院给了委员会10天时间再试一次。而委员会直到第10天，也就是最后一天，2022年2月17日才开会。而这一次——
The commission just didn't pass a map.
委员会根本没有通过地图。
Again, Katy Shanahan.
还是凯蒂·沙纳汉。
The Republicans never offered any map. They just didn't do it. And they filed with the court, saying, yeah, sorry, we just reached an impasse. We don't know-- we don't know how to get around it, you know? We don't know how to make you all happy on the court. The Democrats don't want to agree to any of our maps. So I guess we're just not going to have a map.
共和党人从来没有提供任何地图。他们只是没有这样做。他们向法院提交文件，说，是的，抱歉，我们只是陷入了僵局。我们不知道——我们不知道怎么绕过它，你知道？我们不知道怎么让你们法院里的所有人满意。民主党人不想同意我们的任何地图。所以我想我们就不会有地图了。
The mapmakers, the majority mapmakers, are telling us that they don't believe that we can constitutionally do what the court majority has asked us to do.
制图者，多数派制图者，正在告诉我们，他们不相信我们能在宪法上做到法院多数派要求我们做的事情。
This is Republican Secretary of State Frank LaRose at that February hearing.
这是共和党州务卿弗兰克·拉罗斯在二月份的那次听证会上。
This is one of those classic cases of what we want versus what we can accomplish. Those who are looking to cast blame and score political points will perhaps represent that the situation we're in is simply because of a lack of will. I don't believe that that's the case.
这是我们想要的东西与我们可以实现的东西之间经典的案例之一。那些试图归咎责任并获取政治分数的人可能会说，我们所处的境地仅仅是因为缺乏意愿。我不相信那是真的。
Just to be clear about this, the Republicans are right when they say that it's not so easy to make a map for Ohio that gives Democrats nearly half the districts like the constitution mandates. Because like in many states, the Democrats in Ohio are mostly bunched up in the big cities. In lots of counties, there just aren't so many of them.
为了清楚起见，当共和党人说为俄亥俄州制作一张像宪法强制规定的那样给民主党近一半选区的地图并不容易时，他们是对的。因为像许多州一样，俄亥俄州的民主党人大多聚集在大城市。在很多县，他们的人数并不多。
So to give them enough districts without breaking any of the other rules, like splitting up counties and townships, it's tricky. Democrats, however, and nonpartisan groups like the League of Women Voters say it isn't that hard a problem. That same day, February 17, the Democrats introduced a map that they made that gave them the number of districts that the Supreme Court said would be constitutionally correct.
所以要在不破坏任何其他规则的情况下给他们足够的选区，比如分裂县和乡镇，这很棘手。然而，民主党人和像“妇女选民联盟”这样的无党派团体说，这不是一个那么困难的问题。同一天，2月17日，民主党人介绍了一张他们制作的地图，给予了他们最高法院所说的宪法上正确的选区数量。
All other requirements of the constitution are met. No one has shown constitutional violations in these maps, so I urge a yes vote for adoption of the maps that have been proposed in this motion.
满足了宪法的所有其他要求。没有人显示这些地图中有违宪违规行为，所以我敦促投赞成票以采用该动议中提出的地图。
The Republicans disagreed about the constitutionality and spent a lot of the hearing trying to shoot holes in the map. Their biggest beef-- Matt Huffman said that this map made so many districts of incumbent Republicans vanish, so many that it disfavored one party in a way that the constitution prohibits.
共和党人不同意关于宪法性的看法，并在听证会上花了很多时间试图在地图上找茬。他们最大的不满——马特·赫夫曼说这张地图使得如此多的现任共和党人选区消失了，以至于这以宪法禁止的方式不偏袒某一方。
Democrats replied that so many Republican districts were vanishing because they'd been unfairly gerrymandered in the first place. At the end of the hearing, the Republicans voted down the Democrats' map, like they did with every Democratic map offered during all these hearings, and decided to notify the state Supreme Court that no map could possibly be drawn to comply with the constitution.
民主党人反驳说，如此多的共和党选区消失了，是因为它们首先就是被不公平地划分了。听证会结束时，共和党人否决了民主党人的地图，就像他们在所有这些听证会期间否决了每一个民主党地图一样，并决定通知州最高法院，不可能绘制出任何符合宪法的地图。
And they just sort of crossed their hands and went with the impasse. Which was fairly astounding because you know, a court order is nothing to scoff off. It's the highest court in our state demanding that you redraw a map. And the commissioners just said-- yeah, no, we're not gonna do that. And had no qualms about not only doing that, but then filing paperwork with the court to explain-- yeah, we're just not gonna follow your court order.
他们只是交叉双臂，选择了僵局。这相当令人震惊，因为你知道，法院命令是不容忽视的。这是我们州最高法院要求你重新绘制地图。而委员们只是说——是的，不，我们不会那样做。而且不仅这样做，随后还向法院提交文件解释——是的，我们只是不会遵守你的法院命令，这毫无愧疚。
And of the five Republican commissioners, four of them are barred attorneys who swear an oath to uphold the constitution of the United States and of Ohio, and to have respect and deference to courts who have jurisdiction over your actions, and that's how you're going to behave, you're just gonna cross your arms and say, yeah, no, I'm not gonna comply with that that court order. It's appalling.
而在五名共和党委员中，有四名是持有律师资格的执业律师，他们宣誓维护美国和俄亥俄州的宪法，并对拥有你们行为管辖权的法院表示尊重和顺从，而这就是你们的行为方式，你们只是交叉双臂说，是的，不，我不会遵守那个法院命令。这令人震惊。
Seven days later, the Ohio Supreme Court issued an order for the commissioners to appear in person and explain why they should not be held in contempt for not turning in a map as ordered. Again, Katy Shanahan.
七天后，俄亥俄州最高法院发布命令，要求委员们亲自出庭，解释为什么他们不应因未按命令提交地图而被判藐视法庭。还是凯蒂·沙纳汉。
And what's so wild about the timing of that-- so that order came out on February 24. And later that same day, Republican commissioners managed to propose a new map and pass it almost along party lines.
而关于那个时机最狂野的事情是——那个命令在2月24日发出。而就在同一天晚些时候，共和党委员们设法提出了一张新地图并几乎按党派路线通过了它。
Hmm.
嗯。
Which is fascinating, because they had just argued in court why they couldn't possibly come up with a new map. And yet, fewer than 24 hours after the court said, OK, well, then you should come into court and explain why you didn't-- why you shouldn't be held in contempt, they managed to figure out how to draw a new one.
这很有趣，因为他们刚刚在法庭上争辩为什么他们不可能拿出一张新地图。然而，在法院说，好的，好吧，那么你应该来到法庭解释为什么你没有——为什么你不应该被判藐视法庭后的不到24小时，他们设法想出了如何绘制一张新地图。
And was the new map very different?
那么新地图有什么不同吗？
No, it was not very different. It was largely the same. They made the seat count perhaps a little more palatable, but essentially, one of the driving--
不，没有太大不同。它基本上是一样的。他们让席位数量也许更令人可以接受了一些，但本质上，其中一个驱动——
In fact, the new map finally got to a 54-46 split between Republican and Democratic leaning districts like the court wanted. But just like the previous Republican map, lots of the Democratic seats-- in fact, nearly half of them, 19 seats, were just barely Democratic. They were toss-ups. None of the Republican seats were toss-ups. They were all solid red.
事实上，新地图最终达到了法院想要的共和党和民主党倾向选区之间54-46的比例。但就像之前的共和党地图一样，许多民主党席位——事实上，几乎是一半，19个席位，只是勉强是民主党的。它们是五五开的。共和党席位中没有一个是五五开的。它们全是稳固的红色。
So the Supreme Court ordered the commission to go back and try it one more time. This is now the fourth time. And this time, the court suggested a complete revamp, like a total rethinking of how they were going about this. The court pointed out that one big problem with all these maps was that the Democrats and Republicans didn't draft them together as a group, like the constitution tells them to.
所以最高法院命令委员会回去再试一次。这是第四次了。而这一次，法院建议进行彻底的改组，比如彻底重新思考他们处理这件事的方式。法院指出，所有这些地图的一个大问题是民主党人和共和党人没有像宪法告诉他们的那样作为一个团体一起起草。
So the court said, try drafting a map together from scratch in public. Hire an independent mapmaker to help, somebody who will answer to all the commission members, not just to the Republicans. And incredibly, that's what happens next.
所以法院说，试着在公开场合从零开始一起起草地图。聘请一位独立的制图师来帮忙，一个会对所有委员会成员负责的人，而不仅仅是对共和党人负责。令人难以置信的是，接下来发生的就是那样。
At this time, we'll call up the mapmakers.
现在，我们要叫制图师上来。
They hire two independent mapmakers, one picked by the Democrats and one picked by the Republicans.
他们聘请了两名独立制图师，一名由民主党人选择，另一名由共和党人选择。
We've been waiting a long time to have this opportunity to actually talk with you. Could you just do a brief introduction, please?
我们等了很久才有了这次机会真正与你们交谈。你们能做一个简短的介绍吗，请？
This is the one time in all the hearing footage that I've watched that I've seen co-chair Vernon Sykes allow a faint smile to cross his face. And the commission puts the two to work, in a room in the capitol with cameras and microphones, broadcasting onto the internet with separate feeds that show what was on their computer screens. Senator Sykes was proud of it.
这是我观看的所有听证会录像中唯一一次，我看到联合主席弗农·赛克斯允许一丝淡淡的微笑浮现在他的脸上。委员会让两人开始工作，在议会大厦的一个房间里，有摄像机和麦克风，在互联网上广播，有单独的频道显示他们电脑屏幕上的内容。赛克斯参议员为此感到自豪。
It was totally an open process, live streamed. 24/7, around the clock, this room was broadcast.
这是一个完全公开的过程，实时直播。24/7，全天候，这个房间都在广播。
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
We could hear conversations. This was unheard of in any state anywhere.
我们可以听到对话。这在任何地方的任何州都是闻所未闻的。
And so do you feel like, OK, it's been a bumpy road, but finally there's real hope that this will work out the way that you had wanted from the beginning?
所以你是否觉得，好吧，这是一个坎坷的道路，但终于有真正的希望，它会像你从一开始想要的那样运作？
Absolutely, absolutely.
绝对，绝对。
I mean, it was Ohio's version of reality television. You know, for all the data and map nerds and redistricting nerds--
我的意思是，这是俄亥俄州版的现实电视。你知道，对于所有数据和地图书呆子以及选区重划书呆子——
This is the other Democrat on the redistricting commission, Allison Russo, the Democratic leader in the Ohio House of Representatives. Russo's first entrance into politics in Ohio, years before this, was collecting signatures for redistricting reform at her local public library. So she especially loved this new path they were on. She watched the live stream.
这是选区重划委员会的另一位民主党人艾利森·鲁索，她是俄亥俄州众议院的民主党领导人。鲁索在俄亥俄州政治中的第一次进入，是在这几年前，是在她当地的公共图书馆收集选区重划改革的签名。所以她特别喜欢他们正在走的新道路。她观看了直播。
Everybody did. We all did. I mean, one of the more entertaining aspects was really just the personalities of the two mapmakers and how they interacted with each other. And there were moments of tension.
每个人都看了。我们都看了。我的意思是，更具娱乐性的方面之一实际上只是两位制图师的个性以及他们如何相互互动。而且有紧张的时刻。
So-- so let's not--
所以——所以不要——
There's no discussion.
没有讨论。
So let's not--
所以不要——
There's no discussion. But it-- but when it came to Green--
没有讨论。但它——但当谈到格林——
You don't get to say there's no discussion and then keep discussing.
你不能说没有讨论，然后继续讨论。
I wasn't saying there was no--
我不是在说没有——
There were also long stretches where they got along. They drank lots of Coke, ate on camera. Michael the Democrat was somebody who seemed utterly uninterested in small talk. Doug the Republican was friendly, chatty. Here, he's looking at his phone.
还有很长一段时间他们相处得很好。他们喝了很多可乐，在摄像机前吃东西。民主党人迈克尔似乎对闲聊毫无兴趣。共和党人道格很友好，健谈。在这里，他正看着他的手机。
[LAUGHS] My daughter-- she texted me saying, "The guinea pigs have been enjoying you guys." [LAUGHS]
（笑声）我女儿——她给我发短信说，“豚鼠一直在享受你们这些家伙。”（笑声）
Michael, all business, says nothing. Typical. Doug turns to the camera, does a quick wave and a smile, gets back to work. In just four long days, these two people, who knew nothing about Ohio's districts, got closer and closer to finishing a map that looked like it could meet all the constitutional guidelines. Again, Allison Russo.
迈克尔，全是公事，什么也没说。典型的。道格转向摄像机，挥了挥手并微笑，回去工作。就在仅仅四天的时间里，这两个对俄亥俄州选区一无所知的人，越来越接近完成一张看起来可以满足所有宪法准则的地图。还是艾利森·鲁索。
Yes, yes. I felt hopeful, and at the moment that it became clear that they were going to come to some sort of map is when the Republicans, specifically the two legislative leaders, seemed to go on overdrive and throwing up more and more obstacles and making it more difficult.
是的，是的。我感到充满希望，而在变得明显他们要达成某种地图的那一刻，共和党人，特别是两名立法领导人，似乎开始超速运转，抛出越来越多的障碍，使它变得更加困难。
For example, asking the mapmakers to take time to add the addresses of all the incumbent office holders to the statewide district maps they were making. At a few points, the mapmakers would ask the Republican lawmakers for input on certain decisions, and they wouldn't give answers.
例如，要求制图师花时间将所有现任公职人员的地址添加到他们正在制作的全州选区地图中。在几点上，制图师会向共和党议员询问某些决策的投入，而他们不会给出答案。
I can't vote yes on something when I don't know what the result of it is.
当我都不知道结果是什么时，我不能投赞成票。
Yeah, I have really the same position. I don't think we know enough, not just on this one, frankly, but on the other ones as well. So--
是的，我确实有同样的立场。我不认为我们知道得足够多，不仅是这个，坦率地说，还有其他的。所以——
Republicans denied that these were delaying tactics. They say it was genuinely difficult to come up with a map that would give Democrats more seats without violating other mapmaking rules in the constitution, so finally after four long days and nights, they're at March 28 of this year, the deadline set by the court to finish the map.
共和党人否认这些是拖延策略。他们说，要拿出一张在不违反宪法中其他地图绘制规则的情况下给民主党更多席位的地图确实很难，所以最后经过四天四夜，到了今年的3月28日，法院设定的完成地图的截止日期。
And on that day, March 28th, the two sides end up in the most dramatic battle they have in these hearings. It starts in the late afternoon, when Senator Huffman addresses the committee.
而在那一天，3月28日，双方在这些听证会上进行了他们之间最戏剧性的战斗。它在下午晚些时候开始，当时赫夫曼参议员向委员会致辞。
I did want to talk a little bit about our timing. So the court order requires that we have this final product to the secretary of STATE today, March 28.
我确实想谈谈我们的时间安排。所以法院命令要求我们今天，3月28日，将这个最终产品交给州务卿。
And he explains that to do that by midnight, to get all the files prepared, et cetera, et cetera, they're going to need to vote by 10:30 that night.
他解释说，为了在午夜前做到这一点，准备好所有文件等等等等，他们将需要在那天晚上10:30之前投票。
And obviously, the court is serious about the deadline. I just wanted to comment, so as of 5:00, we do not have a senate map to consider. And you're nodding, Mr Johnson, so I want to make sure I got that right. As of 5:00, we cannot confirm that we have a constitutional house map, with maybe five hours or so to go in our process.
显然，法院对截止日期很认真。我只是想评论一下，截至5:00，我们没有参议院地图可以考虑。而且你在点头，约翰逊先生，所以我想要确保我理解得对。截至5:00，我们不能确认我们有一张宪法上的众议院地图，距离我们的过程结束可能还有五个小时左右。
So given that, I also want to say, obviously, the court is very, very serious about getting these maps to them on time, and I'm concerned, based on the description of the process that that's going to happen. So I think we need a failsafe, and-- if we're not going to land the plane, as it's said, it would be nice to have a parachute.
所以考虑到这一点，我也想说，显然，法院对准时将这些地图送达它们是非常非常认真的，我感到担忧，基于对过程的描述，这将会发生。所以我认为我们需要一个故障保护，而且——如果我们不能落地飞机，正如人们所说，有一个降落伞会很好。
So Huffman proposes going back to the old map, the last unconstitutional map that the Supreme Court had rejected. His idea is the independent mapmakers try to pretty up the old map to get closer to what the Supreme Court wanted.
所以赫夫曼提议回到旧地图，即最高法院驳回的最后一张违宪地图。他的想法是独立制图师尝试美化旧地图以更接近最高法院想要的。
And that's my motion, Mr. Co-Chair.
这就是我的动议，联合主席先生。
Objection.
反对。
The two Democrats on the committee, Vernon Sykes and Allison Russo, respond first. Sykes, I should say, he's kind of an old school politician who usually goes out of his way to avoid saying anything bad about any of his opponents, but even he can't stop himself.
委员会中的两名民主党人，弗农·赛克斯和艾利森·鲁索，首先做出回应。赛克斯，我应该说，他是一个老派政客，通常竭尽全力避免说任何对手的坏话，但连他自己都无法阻止自己。
That is ridiculous. All the time, money, and resources we've put into coming up with a constitutional map that just need edits that we can make in this time period. To distract us, the staff and the independent map draw, to divert to some other tasks, is ridiculous.
那是荒谬的。我们投入了所有时间、金钱和资源来拿出一张仅仅需要我们可以有时间修改的编辑的宪法地图。要分散我们的注意力，工作人员和独立地图绘制者，去执行其他任务，是荒谬的。
Mr Co-Chair.
联合主席先生。
Leader Russo.
鲁索领导。
Thank you, Mr Co-Chair. I strongly object to this. This is so disingenuous of members of this commission to even suggest that this would be the process that we would use moving forward. The court has ordered us to create a map as a commission starting from scratch, and that is what we have done.
谢谢，联合主席先生。我强烈反对这一点。这对于这个委员会的成员来说太不真诚了，甚至建议这将是我们前进的过程。法院已经命令我们作为一个委员会从零开始创建一张地图，而那就是我们所做的事情。
To totally undercut that at this point, number one, is a slap in the face to Ohio voters and completely disregarding the court order. And I will tell you that we can work as long as we need to. The court would much rather us work and finish this job than to again submit another unconstitutional map that is not drawn by the entire commission and/or submit nothing.
在这一点上完全削弱它，第一，是对俄亥俄州选民的耳光，并且完全无视法院命令。而且我会告诉你，我们可以根据需要工作多久就工作多久。法院宁愿我们要么工作并完成这项工作，要么再次提交另一张不是由整个委员会绘制的违宪地图和/或什么都不提交。
If we even have to go past midnight, I bet the court will be OK if we are a few hours late as long as we get this job done. Otherwise, we will be in contempt again or possibly held in contempt of not following the court's order.
如果我们甚至不得不超过午夜，我打赌如果我们需要几个小时的延误，法院也会没关系的，只要我们完成这项工作。否则，我们将再次被判藐视法庭，或者可能因不遵守法院命令而被视为藐视法庭。
Mr. Co-Chair?
联合主席先生？
Yes.
是的。
Yep. Just a couple responses. First--
是的。只是几个回应。首先——
Again, Senator Matt Huffman.
还是马特·赫夫曼参议员。
Your statement that these mapmakers have come up with a constitutional map-- well, I don't know that that's true, and I'm not sure how you know it's true because we never saw that. These mapmakers, doing a tremendous job in a very short period of time that was dictated by the court, have not produced a Senate map and are not able to confirm that they have provided a constitutional House map. And what I'm simply saying is we have a deadline today. It may be that Leader Russo knows what the Supreme Court is thinking, but the order says today is the day.
你关于这些制图师已经拿出一张宪法地图的陈述——嗯，我不知道那是真的，而且我不确定你怎么知道它是真的，因为我们从来没看到那个。这些制图师，在法庭规定的很短时间内做得非常出色，没有制作出参议院地图，也无法确认他们提供了一张宪法众议院地图。而我简单地说的是，我们今天有一个截止日期。可能是鲁索领导知道最高法院在想什么，但命令说今天是那一天。
In fact, the Supreme Court specifically said in the order, quote, "No requests or stipulations for extension of time shall be filed."
事实上，最高法院在命令中明确表示，引用“不得提交任何延长时间的请求或规定。”
And that we have to do it by today. So that, I mean, that's simply what the order is. If somehow, some way, the mapmaker is able to produce a constitutional map that four members of the commission will support, and that is all done by 10:30, then maybe. But it doesn't appear that that's going to happen. So we have to have something that we can provide to the court today, which is what we're ordered to do.
而且我们必须在今天之前做到。所以那个，我的意思是，那就是命令简单的内容。如果不知何故，无论如何，制图师能够制作出一张将有四名委员会成员支持的宪法地图，并且所有这一切在10:30之前完成，那么也许。但看起来不会发生那种事。所以我们必须有可以今天提供给法院的东西，这就是我们被命令去做的事情。
It seems to be no end to the arrogance of the supermajority. Any other comments?
超级多数派的傲慢似乎无止境。还有其他评论吗？
After that, the commission votes along party lines. They tell staff to make a new version of the old unconstitutional map, though they do allow the independent mapmakers to continue on their independent maps as well. After all, maybe they'll finish on time.
在那之后，委员会按党派路线投票。他们告诉工作人员制作旧违宪地图的新版本，尽管他们也允许独立制图师继续制作他们的独立地图。毕竟，也许他们会准时完成。
The motion is approved and so ordered.
动议被批准并如此命令。
That's very late afternoon, near 6 PM. Then they go into recess. When they reconvene at 9:30 that night, just an hour before the 10:30 deadline Matt Huffman tried to set for them, one of the independent mapmakers they hired, the Republican one, Doug Johnson, gives an update.
那是下午很晚，接近下午6点。然后他们休会。当他们在那天晚上9:30重新开会时，距离马特·赫夫曼试图为他们设定的10:30截止日期仅剩一个小时，他们聘请的独立制图师之一，共和党的那位，道格·约翰逊，给出了一个更新。
So co-chairs, members of the commission, as you've hopefully seen, about an hour, I guess about two hours ago now, we did finish a full house map and distributed that and have moved on to the Senate map. We're making progress as fast as humanly possible in an effort to get this done this evening.
所以联合主席，委员会成员，正如你们希望已经看到的那样，大约一个小时，我想大约两小时前，我们确实完成了一张完整的众议院地图并分发了它，并且已经转到了参议院地图。为了努力今晚完成这项工作，我们正以人类可能的最快速度取得进展。
He says that he figures they'll be finished with the Senate map in 45 minutes or an hour. Then he says that they will still need to do some refinements and tweaks to the House map. Commission members have asked for some revisions that haven't been fixed yet. The House map that they made has Republican majorities in 54% of the districts, like the Supreme Court called for. And unlike the previous unconstitutional map, where all the toss-up districts, 19 of them, were Democratic-leaning, in this new map, the independent one, each party has an equal number of toss-up districts-- three Democratic, three Republican, again, like the Supreme Court called for. Matt Huffman and the Republicans are not having it. This is Bob Cupp, the Republican co-chair.
他说他认为他们会在45分钟或一小时内完成参议院地图。然后他说他们仍然需要对众议院地图进行一些改进和调整。委员会成员要求进行一些还没修复的修订。他们制作的众议院地图在54%的选区中有共和党多数，就像最高法院要求的那样。而且与之前的违宪地图不同，那里所有五五开的选区，19个，都是倾向民主党的，在这张新地图，独立的那张中，每个政党都有同样数量的五五开选区——三个民主党，三个共和党，还是像最高法院要求的那样。马特·赫夫曼和共和党人根本不买账。这是鲍勃·库普，共和党联合主席。
Mr. Co-Chair.
联合主席先生。
Yes.
是的。
I think-- in spite of all of the work that's been done, and I know that the consultants came in and they worked extremely hard, I think it is not feasible to expect that we're going to have that in time to be uploaded to the secretary of state's office in compliance with the court's order. So I would just-- so what I'm going to do is to move, I guess, what has been referred to as the 328 Cupp Plan.
我想——尽管已经做了所有的工作，而且我知道顾问们进来了，他们工作非常努力，我认为期望我们在时间上来得及将其上传到州务卿办公室以符合法院命令是不现实的。所以我只是——所以我打算做的动议，我猜，被称为328库普计划的东西。
This is the map that had been found unconstitutional with some small changes that they'd made since 6 PM.
这是那张被发现违宪但自下午6点以来做了些小改动的地图。
And move that the commission adopt that plan.
并提议委员会采用该计划。
Objection.
反对。
Second the motion.
附议该动议。
Mr. Co-Chair.
联合主席先生。
Leader Russo.
鲁索领导。
Again, this is Democrat Allison Russo. She's been given a handout with information about this newly revised Republican map.
是的，这是民主党人艾利森·鲁索。她拿到了一份关于这张新修订的共和党地图的信息讲义。
Thank you, Mr. Co-Chair. I would just like to say that this process is and this motion and this map that's been put before us is a complete farce. I literally have been handed spreadsheets that have population deviations on them, nothing about partisan lean, nothing about symmetry. This is useless information.
谢谢，联合主席先生。我只是想说这个过程以及这个动议和摆在我们面前的这张地图是一个完全的闹剧。我真的被递给了上面有人口偏差的电子表格，没有任何关于党派倾向的信息，没有任何关于对称性的信息。这是无用的信息。
Bob Cupp tells her that it's a 54 to 46 map, like it had been before. But now, instead of 19 Democratic tossup districts, there were 17. Republicans still have no toss-up districts.
鲍勃·库普告诉她这是一张54比46的地图，就像以前一样。但现在，不是19个民主党五五开选区，而是17个。共和党仍然没有五五开选区。
And your assessment is that this addresses the symmetry concerns by the Supreme Court?
而你的评估是这解决了最高法院提出的对称性担忧？
Symmetry concerns-- that each party has a similar number of tossup districts.
对称性担忧——即每个政党都有相似数量的五五开选区。
This moves closer to it, and it is the best that can be done in the time that was available under the court's requirement to adopt the plan by March the 28th.
这更接近它，而且在法院要求在3月28日之前采用计划的时间内，这是能做到的最好的了。
OK, well, I took a lot of math in college. I would disagree with that.
好的，好吧，我在大学学了很多数学。我不同意这一点。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
She asked if they could recess so commissioners could look at the map and if they can make suggestions to change it. Huffman says there's no time for either. Somebody points out that this was Huffman's problem with the independent mapmakers' map, that the commissioners hadn't seen it and that there wouldn't be time to make suggestions to change it. Huffman repeats, the independent map can't be done by midnight.
她问是否可以休会以便委员们可以查看地图，如果他们可以提出修改建议。赫夫曼说无论是哪一个都没有时间。有人指出这是赫夫曼对独立制图师地图的问题，即委员们没有看到它，而且没有时间提出修改建议。赫夫曼重复，独立地图不可能在午夜前完成。
Mr. Co-Chair, I'm going to make one more motion. I move that we, the commission, directs Eric Clark, who is the commission's attorney with the attorney general's office, to prepare an emergency motion asking the court for an extension of 12 hours.
联合主席先生，我要再做一个动议。我动议我们，委员会，指示埃里克·克拉克，他是委员会与总检察长办公室的律师，准备一份紧急动议，要求法院延期12小时。
I object. Mr. Co-Chair, we have a motion on the floor regarding-- I don't even know if Mr. Clark's available, but we've already, several times, read from the Supreme Court's decision, so--
我反对。联合主席先生，我们有一个关于的动议在桌面上——我甚至不知道克拉克先生是否有空，但我们已经几次宣读了最高法院的决定，所以——
And with that, they vote on the Republican map.
随之，他们对共和党地图进行了投票。
This is a motion to adopt a revised 328 Cupp map.
这是一个采用修订后的328库普地图的动议。
No! No. No! No! No! No! No!
不！不。不！不！不！不！不！
Governor DeWine?
德温州长？
Shame on you. Cheaters. Shame on you. Cheaters! Cheat!
为你们感到羞耻。骗子。为你们感到羞耻。骗子！骗！
Quiet down, please. Please, let's have order. We still have to have order here, please.
请安静一下。请，请保持秩序。我们仍然必须在这里保持秩序，请。
Jen Miller, the executive director of the League of Women Voters, they were the ones who sued to get the Republican maps overturned three times already, was there in the hearing room for this.
“妇女选民联盟”执行主任詹·米勒，他们是起诉推翻共和党地图四次的团体，在听证会现场参加了这次会议。
Fascinatingly, this Ohio redistricting commission, that had blown through so many deadlines that were in the constitution and deadlines given to them by the Ohio Supreme Court, decides that deadlines matter and that they needed to get a map done, and they pass it along a simple majority.
迷人的是，这个在宪法中耗费了如此多截止日期以及俄亥俄州最高法院给予的截止日期的俄亥俄州选区重划委员会，决定截止日期很重要，并且他们需要完成一张地图，然后他们以简单多数票通过了它。
What was it like in the room?
房间里是什么样的？
You know, it was interesting because we all knew that-- [LAUGHS] we knew not to be hopeful, but we were hopeful. And it was just such a letdown. Just disappointed, kind of like when you-- you've got a crush on a guy, [LAUGHS] and you think that he's finally going to do the right thing, and then he still doesn't. And you kind of, in your gut, knew that would probably happen. But you're hopeful. I cried, Ira. I cried.
你知道，这很有趣，因为我们都知道——（笑声）我们知道不要充满希望，但我们确实充满了希望。而这真是一个大失望。只是失望，就像当你——你对一个家伙着迷，（笑声）而你认为他终于要做正确的事情了，然后他仍然没有做。而在你的肠子里，你那种可能预感到那种事会发生。但你充满了希望。我哭了，艾拉。我哭了。
You cried.
你哭了。
Yeah. Because I had done nothing. [LAUGHS] I had spent all of my time living and breathing and dreaming maps.
是的。因为我什么都没做。（笑声）我把所有的时间都用来生活、呼吸和梦想地图。
Allison Russo told me she feels sure the Supreme Court would have granted them an extension because, for the first time, the commission was drafting a map together, in public, exactly like the court had called for. But you know, really, there's no need to speculate about this.
艾利森·鲁索告诉我，她确信最高法院会批准他们的延期，因为这是第一次委员会在一起、在公开场合、完全按照法院要求的那样起草地图。但你知道，真的，不需要对这件事进行猜测。
Hello?
你好？
Hello. Is this Justice O'Connor?
你好。请问是奥康纳法官吗？
Yes.
是的。
Yes, this is Ira.
是的，我是艾拉。
Hi, how are you?
你好，你好吗？
Meet Maureen O'Connor, the Chief Justice of the Ohio Supreme Court, at least through December when she retires. A lifelong Republican and the swing vote that rejected Ohio's election maps as gerrymandered seven times this past year, she knew all about the map that had been made by the independent mapmakers. I told her how the commission never submitted it because they were afraid they wouldn't make their deadline.
会见俄亥俄州最高法院首席大法官莫琳·奥康纳，至少到十二月她退休为止。一位终身共和党人，也是过去一年七次驳回俄亥俄州选区划分不公选举地图的摇摆投票者，她对独立制图师制作的地图了如指掌。我告诉她委员会从来没有提交它，因为他们担心赶不上截止日期。
OK, that is-- what can I say? If that was their understanding, contacting the court at 9:00 at night, whatever, would have been, can we have 24 more hours? Absolutely. That would have happened. Would we have rejected something that was given to us at 9:00 in the morning? Absolutely not. Absolutely not.
好的，那是——我能说什么呢？如果那是他们的理解，晚上9点联系法院，无论什么，都会是，我们可以多要24小时吗？绝对。那本来会发生的。我们会拒绝在早上9点给我们的东西吗？绝对不会。绝对不会。
Here's how this played out. Some Republican allies took the case to federal court where a three-judge panel with two Trump appointees told the redistricting commission, if you can't come to an agreement on a map that's constitutional, well, you just use the Republicans' unconstitutional gerrymandered map. After that, unsurprisingly, the commission didn't even try to come to an agreement on a map, never even held a meeting with that purpose. That's why Ohio is going to the polls this week on the gerrymandered maps.
这就是事情的发展。一些共和党盟友将案件带到了联邦法院，在那里，一个有两名特朗普任命者组成的三个法官小组告诉选区重划委员会，如果你不能就一张符合宪法的地图达成一致，嗯，你们就使用共和党违宪的选区划分不公地图。在那之后，不出所料，委员会甚至没有尝试就地图达成一致，从来没有举行过以那个为目的的会议。这就是为什么俄亥俄州本周在选区划分不公的地图上进行投票。
I got interested in all this, wondering how lawmakers could defy their own constitution over and over. I'm talking about Huffman, the person who drove this process more than anybody else. Here's what I learned. In his telling, Republicans were not defying the Supreme Court. He says they tried to comply, and the court kept telling them no. He thinks the court's rulings misread the constitution.
我开始对所有这些感兴趣，想知道立法者如何能够一次又一次地无视他们自己的宪法。我说的是赫夫曼，那个比任何人都更推动这个过程的人。这就是我学到的。按照他的说法，共和党人并没有无视最高法院。他说他们试图遵守，而法院一直告诉他们不。他认为法院的裁决误读了宪法。
The way Matt Huffman reads this part of the constitution, which, of course, he had a big hand in writing, he believes that if you follow all the kind of mechanical rules for how to draw maps, keeping districts compact, not dividing counties too many times, that kind of thing, then you actually can ignore the part of the rules that are about proportional fairness, the rules that dictate how many districts go to each party.
马特·赫夫曼阅读宪法这部分的方式，当然，他在书写方面起了很大作用，他相信，如果你遵循所有用于绘制地图的机械规则，保持选区紧凑，不过多划分县，那类事情，那么你实际上可以忽略那些关于比例公平的规则，那些规定每个政党获得多少选区的规则。
This section about proportional voting is not required. It's aspirational only.
关于比例投票的这一节不是必需的。它只是有志向的。
Of course, the Supreme Court of Ohio sees that very differently. But there is wording in there that Huffman can point to. One of the things that Chief Justice O'Connor told me was that she thought that most Ohioans don't understand what kind of flawed, leaky boat this constitutional amendment is.
当然，俄亥俄州最高法院对此有着非常不同的看法。但其中有赫夫曼可以指出的措辞。奥康纳大法官告诉我的事情之一是，她认为大多数俄亥俄州人并不明白这个宪法修正案是一艘多么有缺陷、漏水的船。
And I think Huffman really believed from the start that when they wrote this language, he'd created rules that would allow him to get his map through, that would let him get any map through with any mix of Democratic and Republican districts because he believes, again, that the language in the constitution says that if you follow all the other rules in drawing districts, it doesn't matter how many districts each party gets.
而且我认为赫夫曼真的从一开始就相信，当他们写这段语言时，他创造了规则，这将允许他让他的地图通过，这将让他让任何地图通过，带有任何民主党和共和党选区的组合，因为他相信，还是那样，宪法中的语言说，如果你在绘制选区时遵循所有其他规则，每个政党获得多少选区并不重要。
In fact, we know from court documents that he instructed the Republican mapmakers to get everything else about the maps correct. Be sure to follow all those other rules, and don't worry about how many districts you give to the Democrats. But beyond that, in a bigger way, Huffman told me he thinks that there are real limits to what courts can tell legislators to do, just in general.
事实上，我们从法庭文件中知道，他指示共和党制图师纠正地图的其他所有内容。一定要遵循所有那些其他规则，不要担心你给民主党多少选区。但除此之外，以一种更大的方式，赫夫曼告诉我，他认为法院可以告诉立法者做什么，只是总体而言，存在真正的限制。
And not long after Huffman and I talked, Republicans in Ohio took one of their redistricting cases to the US Supreme Court. Basically, it's like a North Carolina case you may have heard of that the court is going to hear this year, where one side is arguing that the state supreme courts have no power at all over any state legislatures. Fifty state chief justices, Republicans and Democrats, filed a brief with the Supreme Court arguing against that point of view.
而在赫夫曼和我交谈后不久，俄亥俄州的共和党人将他们的一项选区重划案件带到了美国最高法院。基本上，这就像你可能听说过的北卡罗来纳州案件，法院今年要听审，其中一方辩称州最高法院对任何州立法机关根本没有任何权力。五十位州首席大法官，共和党人和民主党人，向最高法院提交了一份反对那种观点的简报。
OK, so what happens next? Well, even while they're arguing that state supreme court justices should have less power, Republicans in Ohio right now are fighting to get different justices onto the state supreme court, justices who might agree with Matt Huffman's arguments and approve Republican maps that the current court rejects as unconstitutional. Three seats on the court are open.
好的，接下来会发生什么？嗯，即使在他们辩称州最高法院大法官应该拥有更少权力的同时，俄亥俄州的共和党人现在正在为让不同的法官进入州最高法院而奋斗，法官们可能同意马特·赫夫曼的论点，并批准法院驳回为违宪的共和党地图。法院有三个席位空缺。
Every time the court rejected the Republican maps, it was by the narrowest margin, a four to three vote. The two parties have spent over $10 million on these Supreme Court races so far, the Republicans outspending the Democrats nearly two to one. The campaigns are unashamedly partisan. Here's one of the Republican supreme court candidates speaking at an event at a boathouse about the three judicial candidates.
每次法院驳回共和党地图时，都是以最窄的幅度，四比三的投票。两个党派在这些最高法院竞选中已经花费了超过1000万美元，共和党人的支出几乎是民主党人的两倍。竞选活动毫无羞耻地具有党派性。这是一位共和党最高法院候选人在船屋举行的活动中谈到三名司法候选人时的讲话。
If you vote for three and all three win, we take back conservative control of the court, if that's important to you.
如果你投票给三个人，且三个人都赢了，我们就收回法院的保守派控制权，如果这对你很重要的话。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
And just for myself, don't forget, that's Fischer with a C for the constitution and common sense. Thanks.
就我而言，别忘了，那是带着代表宪法和常识的C的费舍尔。谢谢。
If electing justices who will side with Matt Huffman's reading of the constitution is the Republican hope right now, the Democrats and good government groups have drawn other conclusions from their exhausting year-long slog at the redistricting commission. Here's Jen Miller of the League of Women Voters.
如果选举会站在马特·赫夫曼宪法阅读立场上的法官是共和党人现在的希望，民主党人和良政团体已经从他们选区重划委员会长达一年的令人精疲力竭的艰苦工作中得出了其他结论。这是“妇女选民联盟”的詹·米勒。
The lesson is that politicians are going to be politicians, and we have to take them out of the equation completely.
教训是政客终究会是政客，我们必须把他们完全剔除出这个等式。
How?
怎么做？
I don't-- we're going to have to have another ballot initiative. It's going to be hard. It's going to be expensive. It's going to take a long time. But if you look around the states and see which places redistricting went well, they were independent, balanced commissions.
我不知道——我们将不得不进行另一次投票倡议。这会很困难。这会很昂贵。这需要很长时间。但如果你环顾各州，看看哪些地方选区重划做得好，它们都是独立的、平衡的委员会。
Independent in this case means it's not politicians or public officials drawing the maps.
在这种情况下，独立意味着不是政客或公职人员绘制地图。
If you want to imagine another way that things could've gone in Ohio this year, you can just look at New York State. In New York, it was the Democrats who run the state who drew a heavily gerrymandered map. They gave themselves majorities in 22 of the state's 26 congressional districts that determine who goes to the US House of Representatives. This year New York, like Ohio, had a brand new constitutional amendment to stop gerrymandering. And this year, the New York State Supreme Court struck down the Democrat's gerrymandered map as illegal, unconstitutional.
如果你想想象在俄亥俄州今年可能发生的另一种方式，你可以看看纽约州。在纽约，是管理该州的民主党人绘制了一张严重选区划分不公的地图。他们在该州26个国会选区中的22个中给了自己多数优势，这些选区决定了谁去美国众议院。今年纽约，像俄亥俄州一样，有了一个全新的宪法修正案来停止选区划分不公。而今年，纽约州最高法院以非法、违宪为由驳回了民主党人选区划分不公的地图。
A special master appointed by the court redrew the map. The number of safe Democratic districts dropped from 22 to just 15. And  the Democrats stopped fighting. They accepted the court's ruling. That's the map the state will go to the polls with this week.  It'll be that much harder, seven seats harder, for Democrats to keep their control of the US House of Representatives with this un-gerrymandered map.
法院任命的一位特别主管重新绘制了地图。稳固的民主党选区数量从22个下降到只有15个。而民主党人停止了战斗。他们接受了法院的裁决。那是该州本周去投票时将带着的地图。对于民主党人来说，带着这张没有选区划分不公的地图来保持对美国众议院的控制将困难得多，七个席位更难。
And why did the Democrats in New York accept the court's ruling?  Well for starters, it would've been a lot harder for the Democrats to keep fighting for their illegal map because New York's constitution lets the Supreme Court appoint a special master who works for the court  to draw a new map, and then the court can impose that new map on the entire state.
为什么纽约的民主党人接受了法院的裁决？嗯，首先，民主党人要为他们违法的地图继续战斗会困难得多，因为纽约的宪法允许最高法院任命一位为法院工作的特别主管来绘制一张新地图，然后法院可以强加那张新地图到整个州。
Ohio's constitution doesn't have anything like that. In fact, the wording in the constitution specifically prohibits it, thanks to Matt Huffman and the Republicans. If a map is bad, if it gerrymanders, the constitution throws the job of redrawing back to politicians on the redistricting commission, who can basically stonewall. And so Republicans in Ohio never redrew their map to give the court what it asked for.
俄亥俄州的宪法没有任何类似的东西。事实上，宪法中的措辞明确禁止它，这要感谢马特·赫夫曼和共和党人。如果一张地图很糟糕，如果它存在选区划分不公，宪法就把重划的工作抛回给选区重划委员会的政客，他们基本上可以拖延。所以俄亥俄州的共和党人从来没有重划他们的地图来给法院它所要求的。
And they hope they'll never have to, when they get a new set of justices on the court this next year.
他们希望他们永远不必那样做，当他们在明年得到法院的一组新法官时。
[MUSIC - "I'LL DO IT ANYWAY" BY THE LEMONHEADS]
（音乐 - 柠檬头乐队的“我还是要那样做”）
Our program was produced today by Zoe Chace and Valerie Kipnis. People who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Chris Benderev, Sean Cole, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Charlotte Sleeper, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, and our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由佐伊·蔡斯和瓦莱丽·基普尼斯制作。整理今天节目的人包括埃尔纳·贝克、克里斯·本德雷夫、肖恩·科尔、斯托·纳尔逊、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、夏洛特·斯利珀、莉莉·沙利文、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。我们的管理编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。
I first learned about the redistricting fight in Ohio reading Jane Mayer's article in the New Yorker not long ago about the Republican supermajority there, how it passes laws that are much more red than Ohio's population, which I recommend.
我第一次了解俄亥俄州的选区重划斗争是读了简·梅耶不久前在《纽约客》上发表的关于那里共和党超级多数派的文章，它是如何通过比俄亥俄州人口更红的法律的，我推荐这篇文章。
A special thanks today to David Niven and Dan Tokaji, who both helped with map analysis, and to Eric French and Leticia Wiggins from WOSU, who recorded most of these interviews.
今天特别感谢戴维·尼文和丹·托卡吉，他们都对地图分析提供了帮助，以及来自WOSU的埃里克·弗伦奇和莱蒂西亚·威金斯，他们记录了大部分采访。
Also thanks to Robert Cupp, John Fortney, Aaron Mulvey, Dennis Kucinich, Freda Levenson, Yurij Rudensky, Michael McDonald, Ann Henkener, Keary McCarthy, Karen Kasler, Andy Chow, Chris Welter, Ilya Maritz, Mallory Golski, Maya Majikas, Myla Danison, Jeff Rusnak, Chris Davey, Bishop Lord, and of course, Sheldon Harnick.
还要感谢鲍勃·库普、约翰·福特尼、亚伦·马尔维、丹尼斯·库西尼奇、弗雷达·列文森、尤里·鲁登斯基、迈克尔·麦克唐纳、安·亨克纳、基里·麦卡锡、卡伦·卡斯勒、安迪·周、克里斯·韦尔特、伊利亚·马里茨、马洛里·戈尔斯基、玛雅·马吉卡斯、迈拉·丹尼森、杰夫·鲁斯纳克、克里斯·戴维、洛德主教，当然还有谢尔顿·哈尼克。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also merch for your holiday shopping-- is it too soon to say that? I just said it. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过750集的档案。还有你节日购物的周边产品——说这个太早了吗？我刚说了。还是，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所，传递给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, or as he calls himself, Torey C. Malatia.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生，或者正如他自己所称呼的那样，托里·C·马拉蒂亚。
With a C for the constitution and common sense.
带着代表宪法和常识的C。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of "This American Life."
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多“《美国生活》”的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "I'LL DO IT ANYWAY" BY THE LEMONHEADS]
（音乐 - 柠檬头乐队的“我还是要那样做”）